president biden is in his speech today
to defend unpopular vaccine mandates
i want to start by acknowledging how
tired
worried and frustrated i know you are
i know how you're feeling are we going
back to march 2020 not just last march
2021
but march 2020 when the pandemic first
hit
and that's what i keep getting asked the
answer is absolutely no i know
vaccination requirements are unpopular
for many
i'm not even popular for those who are
anxious to get them
my administration has put them in place
not to control your life but to save
your life
policies like that have done a number on
his deeply damaged presidency biden's
disapproval continues to soar 55 percent
think he's doing a terrible job seven
and 10 say this year was a bad year for
the country
you know uh
jesse we were talking in the break that
there's
he has no
power to express any optimism it's so
it's like you have people that
yeah yeah they think this year is bad
but they also think next year is going
to suck because he can't tell he can't
express a glimmer of hope and he and he
told us that this year was going to be
great yes and being a president is kind
of like being a parent you have to
manage expectations we take the twins on
a car ride to maine from new york yes
depending on when you leave depending on
how much traffic it's either six to
eight hours the night before we leave i
don't tell the twins we're going to get
there in three hours
they're they're going to be cranky and
confused and they're not going to trust
me the next day and that's how the
people feel they're cranky confused and
they're distrustful of the president the
guy ran on crushing the virus said trump
didn't crush it and then declared this
summer that he crushed it and now you
have two successive waves and people
don't think you're credible after that
you pull back your mandates that you
said you weren't going to do people
don't think you're credible
anthony fauci remember what did you say
his favorite words could be might be
maybe that chips away at your
credibility and now he says no one saw
these waves coming
i saw the waves coming i text people
people smarter than i am i know you
don't think so but they're probably
smarter than i am and they told me this
summer yeah this august is going to be
bad they told me as i saw the charts go
up this winter not as bad as last winter
but it's going to be a rough winter how
does he not have people in the office to
tell him that stuff he should be fired
on the spot
how do i know that a lot of people go
get tested before thanksgiving and
christmas and he doesn't see that coming
how do i know that this thing is
seasonal and reasonable and he doesn't
know it's seasonal and reasonable so
this guy's out of his mind right now and
you have to ramp up testing after what
we spent two trillion dollars on what we
don't have tests after two trillion
dollars where'd the money go i've always
thought it was embezzled but that's just
me and
you can't you can't go out there and you
said it you can't whisper
to the american people you can't whisper
and you can't cough while you're
whispering and expect people to pay
attention he's not clear or loud enough
you know i'm gonna dana i'm gonna
piggyback on his parent analogy it seems
like biden's like the dad who's driving
the station wagon and he's lost and the
kids are in the back seat they're
america going where are we where are we
and he's saying it we're all good we're
all good we're all good and he's like
already just crossed the border into
some stop and ask for directions
like stop hitting your sister yes
so you could do a little reverse
psychology on america because what the
question here in this block is does he
have any political capital left looking
at the poll numbers i would say it's
dwindling and then you have build back
better that falls apart why not start
his speech with something that says
america i want to thank you
you have done everything we asked you an
amazing numbers you have gotten
vaccinated you stayed home and i know
that was hard for you i know a lot of
your businesses suffered we are so
grateful for the taxpayer support to
make sure like imagine all the things
that you could do to make people feel
like
okay you're bringing me along instead
immediately it's like boom boom and
remember the vaccine mandate was a
distraction
in during afghanistan yeah it was a
friday afternoon in up in the middle of
august and all of a sudden he's going to
give a speech okay great he's going to
maybe tell us like what's going to
happen here are we going to be able to
have an extra time to get these people
out and sydney comes on and said we're
going to have a vaccine mandate and that
was super confusing he need if they're
going to change something
in the coverage they have to have
something or somebody new yeah and they
could have done that today or he could
have berated the fda he's basically
today one of the things he said was that
goldman sachs says things are going to
be okay like is that what the base wants
to hear yeah they've been real good at
that
yeah
to danis a point here is that he might
not be the right person for this moment
he seems almost entirely divorced from
the mood of the country it's because he
is the farthest humanoid away from being
persuader in chief the only people he is
persuasive with are people who already
agree with him and they're the type of
people who will agree with bette midler
yes
uh he is you're not a persuader if you
vilify the unvaccinated which he
continues to do he did it again today
you're not a persuader talking about the
winner of death if you hate republicans
in tribal and are tribal you're not a
persuader where it divides and the most
stark thing and we already mentioned is
the fact that he did not come out and
say
this week as based on reports the merck
and pfizer anti-viral pills
are going to be approved this week and i
i hate to keep pivoting back to
president trump but trump trusted and
valued and wanted to
cheer the private sector yeah and these
incredible things while the left
elizabeth warren is blaming inflation on
grocery stores so you can't
know biden would stand up there and and
and cheer the pharmaceutical companies
yeah as trump once said paraphrase
people who work in government are stupid
that should have been him those people
are slow and stupid they're bureaucrats
and we'll go over there and shake some
marbles
out of their skull and get them to
approve these antivirals we're on the
way to recovery and stopping the
pandemic why how come they've been so
slow in these therapeutics especially
this pill that we keep hearing about doc
well the administrative bloat of the fda
is just long-standing and has always
been there president trump through
operation warp speed was able to cut a
lot of that trump i will say that
bloomberg reported today that the fda
announced that
the eu way from monu pirovir as well as
paxlovid could be
as proved as early as tomorrow great
news but it's not just about that it's
also about fluvoxamine which is an
existing medicine a lot of medicines i'm
going to have to learn how to pronounce
that let's slow that one down doctor but
flavoxamine is an existing medication
that is being repurposed it is shown to
prevent death and hospitalization up to
90 and it's a cheap medication that you
can get from your pharmacy why aren't we
talking about antidepressants so you get
a one-two punch
and also the antibodies we are in a dire
shortage of antibody therapy right now
that is where the focus should be if he
truly wants to give that hope to
american people one he should be
transparent about the number
hospitalized of covid patients yes
hospitals are full but it is not with
covid patients we have a flu that's
going around right now that the flu shot
is not being very effective with we also
have a lot of chronic illness and yes
there aren't increasing covert patients
but there is a way to keep them out of
the hospital get these treatments to
them all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else